the Supreme Court this morning will hear
arguments in one of the biggest cases of
its term a battle between religious
liberty and anti-discrimination lines
started forming yesterday for a seat
inside the court justices will hear
arguments from a Colorado Baker who
refused to make a wedding cake for a
same-sex couple in 2012 the court ruled
in 2015 that the Constitution protects
same-sex marriage nationwide and now it
will decide just how far that protection
goes Jan Crawford spoke to both parties
in this landmark case and she joins us
from outside the court this morning Jan
good morning well good morning so I mean
as you can see this case is attracting a
lot of attention and it pits a right to
free speech and free religion against a
right to be free from discrimination a
devout Christian Baker on the one hand
and a same-sex couple who just wanted a
wedding cake Jack Phillips had been
making wedding cakes for nearly 20 years
when Dave Mullins Charlie Craig and his
mother Debbie Munn walked into his
masterpiece cake shop outside Denver he
asked us who the cake was for and when
we said it was for us he said he would
not make a cut a cake for a same-sex
wedding Mullins and Craig were getting
married in Massachusetts and were
planning a celebration back home in
Colorado we went in so happy and left
broken I was embarrassed that my mom had
to see me go through that and you know I
Fionna I started to break down and I
cried I've tried to respectfully
apologize that I couldn't create this
thing Phillips who grew up drawing and
painting says it's cakes or personal
artistic expressions I serve everybody
who comes in my shop so in this case I
will gladly sell you anything in my shop
but this is just an event that I can't
create a cake
but Tomales and Craig it was
discrimination they filed a complaint
against Phillips and won what we went
through was humiliating and painful and
degrading and we didn't want another
loving couple to have to go through that
but for Phillips the ordeal was also
painful phone calls were coming
harassing swearing at you to where my
wife was afraid to come into the shop
reports just there were tears
what's going on what do we do
Philips stopped making wedding cakes so
we wouldn't be forced to violate his
beliefs and what if the Supreme Court
rules against you if we have to close a
business in order to stand for our faith
that's what we do now Philips his lawyer
says the case could affect all kind of
creative professionals and force them to
create artworks that may conflict
against their religious beliefs but the
couple says this is just a straight-up
case of discrimination Norah really
interesting to hear those arguments Jim
let me ask you about the other big news
out of the Supreme Court them upholding
the president's travel bans that it
would take full effect what can you tell
us about that decision well I mean this
is a win for the president it's a
temporary win but it basically means
that the travel ban can stay in effect
while all these appeals play out that
the Trump administration will be able to
fully enforce this ban until all these
lawsuits are resolved now two judges in
Hawaii and Maryland had had said that
the restrictions on travel Trump's
tribal order had to be limited and that
travelers with bona fide connections to
the United States could not be kept out
of the country but with the supreme
court's order yesterday in most cases
citizens from eight countries will be
unable to enter the United States it
applies to people from six mostly Muslim
countries and North Korea and Venezuela
all right Jan thank you